Comment coller deux livres ensemble ? Et bien,
avec une colle bien forte ! Le problème c'est
que lire les livres après ce sera un peu
plus compliqué.
Tâchons donc de le faire sans colle.
Pour cela je vais avoir besoin de livres et
de deux mains.
Ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va juxtaposer
les pages des livres les unes sur les autres.
Une page d'un livre, une page de l'autre.
Une page du premier, une page du deuxième
et ça jusqu'à avoir à peu près la moitié
des deux livres recouvert les uns sur les
autres.
Une fois cela fait on va prendre les deux
livres et voilà ils tiennent bien ensemble.
On peut secouer un petit peu, ils ne tombent
pas.
On ne voit pas à l’œil nu mais les surfaces
des feuilles de papier ne sont pas lisses.
Elles sont recouvertes de minuscules creux
et bosses un peu comme un mur crépi.
Quand on frotte deux pages ensemble, les bosses
s'accrochent.
C'est ce que l'on appelle la force de frottement.
Cette force est certes très faible mais avec
toutes les pages d'un livre les frottements
s'additionnent et la force devient suffisante
pour porter un livre.
Les pages des deux livres se bloquent entre
elles.
La plupart des objets ont leur surface recouverte
de ces minuscules bosses, c'est ce qui permet
à certains animaux comme les insectes par
exemple de marcher sur les murs et les plafonds.
Les pattes des insectes ont des petites pelotes
rugueuses qui s'accrochent à ces bosses de
la même manière que les pages des livres,
les insectes ne tombent pas des murs et des
plafonds.
Je t'invite à refaire cette expérience chez
toi.
Merci d'avoir regardé cet épisode et je
te donne rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour répondre à une nouvelle question.